whether you're just diving into demon
souls for the first time
or you're revisiting the cult classic
via the ps5 remake
one thing remains true the kingdom of
balataria has a rich
albeit obtuse history if you're curious
about the events that led up to your
adventure then sit back and listen to
our tale
long ago humans lived peacefully under
benevolent rulers
until a lust for power caused the old
one to awaken
the old one is thought to be one of the
most ancient demons in existence
a primordial and unknowable being of
immense power
fueled by an insatiable longing for the
souls of humans it began to create a
thick fog that spread across the land
engulfing entire kingdoms out of this
fog came horrific demons
hungry to devour souls for their
insatiable master
the old one the fog spread quickly
seemingly unstoppable
eventually wiping out over half of the
world until
against all odds the last desperate
vestiges of civilization managed to lull
the old one back into its slumber
saving themselves from complete
extinction the fog retreated but the
damage to humanity had been done
in an attempt to ensure a tragedy of
this nature would never happen again
six elders were trusted to guard six
archstones that were placed across the
land as a means of
inter-regional travel a hidden temple
called the nexus was then built as a
safe haven for lost souls
the soul arts which leveraged the innate
power of souls to perform dark magic
were banned some survivors became
monumentals
half-living beings tasked with
preserving the fabric of reality
stopping the use of soul arts and
warning future generations of the
dangers that could befall them if they
don't listen
as time passed humanity slowly forgot
about the arch stones
and the monumentals began to disappear
the current ruler
king alot the 12th started as a caring
and benevolent leader
he was loved by his subjects and fought
bravely against the demons remaining
from the first scourge
but as alot aged he became dejected and
disheartened
and corruption began to creep in seeking
power for himself and his kingdom
he discovered the nexus and the
long-forgotten soul arts
this gave rise to a new age of
prosperity for the land of bolitaria
but that wasn't enough to placate alan's
thirst for power
so he returned to the nexus and awoke
the old one forming a pact with it
this of course had devastating
consequences with the old one arisen
once more
the fog consumed the lands and from it
the demon army again
emerged to consume souls and wipe out
human existence
the magic of demon soul's story is in
piecing together the journeys that its
characters take
from their previous history to their
actions in the nexus and other regions
but we can't talk about one particular
character without some spoilers
so those who want to experience the game
fresh should retreat now
like all good princes ariona alante
moved to defend his father's honor
perhaps blindly disguised as ostrava of
boletaria
ariona traveled across the kingdom to
dispel the rumors that his father was a
demon himself
at the same time ariona was looking for
his father to see if the rumors were
actually true
boletaria was completely cut off from
the outside world
and anyone who tried to travel through
the deep fog never returned
that was until valorfax the younger of
king allan's twinfang knights
fought his way out valorfax told the
world of boletaria's fallen king
the awoken old one and the
soul-consuming demons that had overrun
the kingdom
if no one can stop the spread of the fog
and the rampage of the demons as it
drifts outside the city walls
humanity will be completely consumed but
of course there is one final hope
that's you the slayer of demons
demon souls is available right now on
ps5
if you're unsure about diving into the
notoriously difficult game yourself
you can check out gamespot's full review
and if you need some help surviving
we have a handy beginner's guide too